quatre binômes en lice pour le plus
grand canton des yvelines celui de
rambouillet la campagne pour les
élections départementales a démarré
samedi dernier les candidats sillonné le
territoire du sud yvelines pour
présenter leurs idées
à l'image du binôme clarisse demont et
geoffroy backs de keating candidat sur
la liste ensemble pour les yvelines de
la majorité sortante
on a un attachement qui est très fort en
tant qu'élu du territoire on a un
attachement très fort au sud yvelines
est ce qu'on souhaite c'est vraiment le
préserver aujourd'hui on a beaucoup
d'urbanisation en ile-de-france qui
s'approchent au fur à mesure vers le sud
yvelines
est ce qu'on souhaite c'est tous
ensemble faire bloc pour protéger ce
cadre de vie c'est tous ces trois thèmes
on va dire préserver tout en innovant
harmonieusement pour l'environnement
sans oublier évidemment les services au
plus près de de la population parmi les
projets du binôme ep y un bus médical
pour répondre aux besoins des déserts
médicaux du canton la santé la mobilité
deux éléments importants aussi pour le
duo soutenu par europe ecologie les
verts constitué de patricia mignot et
david judge et on a comme projet de
permettre à tous les rangs boli temps et
tous les habitants du canton d'avoir
accès à un médecin à une pmi tout ce qui
est nécessaire localement et pas devoir
chercher des médecins jusqu'à trappe
parce que les nouveaux arrivants à
rambouillet ne trouve pas de médecin on
a une grosse problématique sur le sur le
bassin d'emploi de préservation et de
création d'emploi sur notre bassin de
vie et éviter que les personnes ne
soient obligés de faire des heures de
transport pour aller travailler
du côté du rassemblement national la
sécurité et l'enjeu le plus important de
ces départementale d'autant que le 30
avril dernier un attentat contre les
forces de l'ordre s'est produit à
rambouillet c'est un élément qui qui
n'est pas nouveau rassemblement national
c'est la sécurité
c'est d'ailleurs le thème de de jordan
bardella pour les régionales qui n'est
pas notre élection
le choix de la sécurité voilà je pense
que il est évident qu'on ferait dans les
collèges dans certains collèges on
ferait quand même quelques uns peuvent
par là ça c'est certain et justement
l'intérêt du département et de ses
budget qui ai l'argent des yvelinois
c'est de s'en servir à leur fin à leur
utilisation donc c'est tout à fait dans
l'esprit de du rassemblement national et
de notre candidature nation enfin la
dernière candidature sans étiquette
constitué de nathalie stéphane et
mickaël le saunier entend bien défendre
la ruralité et faire en sorte que les
villages du sud yvelines ne soit pas les
oubliés du département ça me semblait
important de poursuivre ce que j'ai
envie de faire c'est à dire remettre
l'humain au sein de l'action politique
aussi au niveau du département et
rajouter un peu plus de concertation et
d'implication des citoyens et des
acteurs locaux dans le département et
moi en parfaite complémentarité avec
nathalie stéphane moi je suis vraiment
pour que le département prennent le
virage du développement durable et
qu'aujourd'hui on ait enfin une
politique où le développement durable
n'est pas une entité en soi mais surtout
quelque chose transversale et qui
intègre en fait toutes les compétences
du département quatre binômes qui
dévoileront au fur et à mesure leurs
programmes complets un mois de campagne
où les restrictions sanitaires en
vigueur contraindront les candidats à
trouver des solutions pour couvrir au
maximum le canton